old friend of the show Chris Collins out
in Western Massachusetts has a great
column in the green field recorder about
an FCC rule that could really crush some
of the platforms on which the David
Pakman show and other independent shows
are distributed Chris wrote about this
Eli Sherman also wrote about it in the
Worcester Telegram which is another
Massachusetts paper and this is actually
about something other than net
neutrality I mean it's sort of related
to net neutrality but it's actually sort
of a parallel issue and I'll explain it
to you this way as many of you know and
many of you don't know the David Pakman
show airs on many television and radio
stations many of these are public radio
stations and public access television
stations we don't make any money from
that okay and in fact it costs us money
that's the reality we devote staff time
and production resources we have file
hosting just to have places to put the
show that we give to these stations and
the reason I don't mind doing it at a
cost
I go we take a loss on that every year
is because I think it's really important
to provide these stations that are often
volunteer run although many of the
bigger ones do have paid staff and that
that are there to serve the community
it's important to provide them good
content most of those stations that have
funding the television ones anyway are
funded when an ISP like Comcast for
example comes into a city or town or
municipality they will be involved in a
negotiation and they will agree that a
certain fee from each cable subscriber
will be allocated and given to the
public access Center I was actually
involved in this when I was on the board
of Northampton Community Television in
Northampton Massachusetts years ago and
there would be a deal where okay you get
15 cents per month I don't know what it
is but 15 cents per month per subscriber
go to funding this cable access center
and then based on the number of
subscribers that the cable access center
predicts there
are in the city they know okay we can
count on twenty five thousand dollars a
year or in medium-size places it might
be more like three hundred thousand
dollars a year or whatever and you've
got to take a station that is funded
great what the FCC now plans to do is to
make the fee that goes to public access
stations part of the total franchise fee
which is capped at five percent total
this would allow the ISPs to deduct the
cost of these public access centers from
the franchise fee and in many cases this
is going to make those stations
completely unviable this is going to
crush the amount of money that gets to
these stations many of which run the
David Pakman show and as Chris Collins
writes in the green field recorder quote
such a change would also appear to have
a political upside for an administration
that has already shown a hearty disdain
for criticism many of today's voices of
dissent have gotten their starts on
public access stations and if the Trump
led FCC can further deregulate an
industry and put a little more coin in
the pockets of the fat cats while at the
same time shutting down the ami
Goodman's
David Pakman and Chris Collins's of the
world not to mention the next generation
of potential analysts so much the better
chris is not optimistic that we can stop
this I'm also not optimistic that we can
stop this this is really bad now
fortunately for us we've developed other
platforms but the problem is many of the
people who watch or listen to cable
access and public radio platforms don't
necessarily have high-speed Internet
access and other ways to access the
David Pakman show so yes this is
outrageous yes please submit a comment
to the FCC telling them you're against
this although we know what their history
is in terms of selective listening I
guess we could call it when it comes to
FCC comments but Pat this is
unfortunately yet another handout to the
ISPs that benefited greatly from Trump's
FCC ending the Obama net neutrality
and it's not good because the attacks on
independent media are coming from all
sides yeah sometimes we talk about
whether Democrats and Republicans are
indeed the same I can guarantee you that
if Hillary Clinton was elected president
in 2016
stuff like this would not be happening
net neutrality would not have been
gutted and in this one too I mean this
is a direct result of the Trump
presidency
no question about it and I I wish I mean
I if you read Chris's piece which we're
linking to and he lies pieces nobody is
sort of putting out a message of hope
the you you've just got to get these
people out I mean that's really it and
unfortunately on a lot of these issues I
like to try to come to you and say
here's how we can stop this here's how
we can undo it with a lot of this stuff
it's just we need different people
making decisions we need different
people deciding who runs the FCC 2018
was this was a step a step but 2020 is
really where the focus needs to be
because so much is riding on it make
sure you follow me on instagram at David
Pakman behind the scenes pictures of the
show oh but we're on the show Instagram
account which is that David Pakman show
we are going to be publishing a updated
picture of the studio room and you would
be shocked at the number of monitors
that I now have in here and I'm up to
four monitors Pat you said you'd like to
get me up to eight monitors and by
Christmas I wonder what people would
think the over-under was for the amount
of monitors in front of you I would put
the over-under at like three but four is
pretty insane yes I think three is what
most people think I have and up to four
now and I'm working on getting two or
three more in here by but by the time we
get back from Thanksgiving week and a
lot of these will just be for watching
Netflix I mean I did they're not even
really crucial to the production of the
show anyway follow the show on instagram
at david pakman show follow me on
instagram at david pakman